all right this morning we have an update
on the issue of control of Congress CBS
News Now estimates Republicans are one
seat away from winning the 218 seats for
a slim majority in the house after
failing to take over the Senate both of
the top GOP leaders on Capitol Hill
House minority leader Kevin McCarthy and
Senate minority leader Mitch McConnell
are facing challenges from within their
party Nicole Killian is following this
for us
before an official called House
Republicans assume the majority
nominating minority leader Kevin
McCarthy as their next speaker the era
of one-party Democrat rule in Washington
is over in a closed-door vote the
California Republican won the backing of
188 members 31 voted against him and he
needs at least 218 when the new Congress
convenes early next year do you think
you will have the votes by January to
become speaker yes we have our work cut
out for us we've got to have a small
majority we've got to listen to
everybody in our conference McCarthy
fended off a last-minute bid by
conservative Arizona Congressman Andy
Biggs some members of the right wing
House Freedom caucus demanded more
concessions While others want a new
leader well I think we can do better
there was also drama in the Senate where
minority leader Mitch McConnell faced
his first leadership challenge in 15
years from Florida Republican Rick Scott
who called for a change from the status
quo I have the votes I will be elected
after attempt three and a half hour
meetings some Senators called for a
delay in this week's election following
the gop's lackluster midterm performance
I've got nothing personal against Mitch
McConnell it is a hard job if you're the
coach of the number one football team in
the country
and you go in and you lose one two three
big games that you're supposed to win
you know what happens that coach gets
fired
McConnell and Scott have been at odds
for months with McConnell arguing that
candidate quality was more important
while Scott who ran the campaign
strategy for Senate Republicans said he
believes that parties should have put
forth a plan to voters Dale
all right to be continued for sure
Nicole thank you